what they're saying is that they stop
teaching sex and they're actually
teaching to refrain from sex right
well no you should everybody's got they
look they've been having sex for years
my mother had my sister when she was 15.
she had me when she was 18. they just
weren't
what are you laughing at you just want
to say it say it no no
shut up and say it don't you dare i
won't say it but you can't say his
mother's a [ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm fighting everybody right now get
back here you
freaking can i say can we say it
bobby
simone culture they have sex very young
children y'all
that's cool i understand and my mother
was can i get back
coming of age and samoa you called my
mother a [ __ ] i didn't
call my great grandmother last time i
was one
of them
oj is not guilty the jury is let's start
with that
a lot of people don't know past about 87
97 no no and
they didn't have jury systems when pat
was young
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you don't know about the jury look i've
never had a worse breakup they all
the same thing women try to force
themselves on me and i get very
frightened
forcing me to call forcing me to listen
when they call forcing me to watch the w
they want to watch on television are
forcing me to take them out
forcing me to wear what they think i
look cute forcing me to play xbox winner
when they're not even interested in the
game they
get pissed away forcing me to forcing me
to cuddle afterwards even in the summer
it's hot [ __ ] i still love you
look at me
look at man ladies if you want to know
how to make your man
happy just think about what makes you
happy
and do exactly the opposite
should colleges be teaching courses on
hip-hop patrice you just recited one
song you heard
all of that was in one song kyle you
even say hip-hop
first of all blues jazz it's it's a
category so it's a music category you
should learn about it
as a culture hip-hop first of all stupid
where's the last time
wait when's the last time you've hung
algebra problem on the bus to get you
through
that long ride it has a
it has a purpose i've never used
geometry i always use
wraps
whatever they're mumbling
rap is important to me i'm not saying
it's important to you it's important to
learn
you think it's your voice yes
so that won't do what you did well
barbary it's burnbury stupid
no matter what happens in the world
nukes middle east famine in this country
we are still
dodging the race issue
look at man in the last year black
people arrested for embezzlement
plagiarism sniping because they're good
and now mass murder and i just wanted to
say that all black people
ever wanted was an opportunity to show
what we can do
[Applause]
i mean if you watch friends you realize
that uh that rachel's not really the the
peacemaker
uh good point holy christ i never
thought i could top your bomb in the
world i know
i'm talking about bombing please bail us
out come on
i'm not gonna be i'm gonna strap one of
your jokes to myself and run through
palestine
starting with nick from detroit
works for a midas muffler
he's working on a barbecue flavored
bikini wax
[Music]
padres he's from the sun
he's uh
he's a struggling actor which means he's
a waiter and he speaks
75 languages fluently all right
you know see the fact that you know so
much about black people is really occurs
to you and your white friends
i'm gonna tell you why colin has a real
knowledge
of like black people for some reason so
when he says these black things he
thinks that all white people know about
community day rooms and you don't
he's a man in purgatory
black people don't like him and white
people don't understand them he don't
know when he's though
patrice o'neill look every black person
has a very good white friend that we
keep tucked away somewhere
and that person always asks why haven't
i met any of your other friends yet
well why you think only white friend i
gotta go back home
and when we wear sports jerseys we don't
really necessarily like that team that
we're wearing it's just that the colors
go nicely with my rims
and
and we all think oj did it but you know
how much a o.j
simpson throwback is it's off the hook
so that's why
all right thank you you mean let's see
if we can get through this without
heckling this poor kid
you want to know this and do it without
doing your mama's
vietnamese voice all right she's right
do it
do it do it do it do it but do like a
german accent
all right do like an accent in there no
no do a french accent come on it'll be
better do it do it it's miss saigon
you won't get anyone to prove to these
guys you got the chops don't worry do it
it'll work
you want to know the awful truth about
asians go to any casino anywhere in the
united states and all the conservative
asians that you see at the dry cleaners
and liquor stores and nail salons are
standing at the tables the craft tables
and
pai gow tables they're like that's it we
gambled our
[Applause]
go to house community college
where we will serve french fries from my
son
oh last night we lost 500 but that won't
happen again
until tomorrow night
[Applause]
if black people have one face to call
the leader of race like of slavery
like because it's too broad we just hate
too many of you
if y'all if you just made like one dude
with a funny mustache and a big bite
like he was the dude that made slavery
you'll be like all right we hate him
and then we can move on yeah yeah
that's very smart i'm telling you the
new york times reported this weekend
that 28
of black males will be behind bars at
some point in their life
and right now 12 percent of all black
men between the ages of 20 and 34
are behind bars which obviously
aggressive patrice what are you doing
here when did you get out no i'm kidding
no dude what do you have to say about
this guy it was funny
it was kind of funny it was very funny
what are you asking me
i'm asking you uh you know what do you
think about why yeah i know why
it's drug is the war on drugs that's
america's way of when they say it's a
war and anything it's really a war on a
particular uh
group right um like the rico statute
that's the rico
that's the war on the mob wait a minute
wait a minute that was a war against
puerto ricans
there we go sorry
do your prepared materials oh god
now look at wait a minute wait a minute
i'm sorry that was that wasn't it
now look what i'm saying is this uh the
it's the drug it's because
they're in there for drugs that's the
that's all they're in there for really
all those that group of minutes and
drugs and then that's the people
selling drugs puerto ricans and and
young blacks that's how they're making a
little money
well first of all don't you think now i
know he's going to jump all over this
one
but don't you think that people say
racism which is what you're kind of
implying now
well i'm trying i i look i'm trying to
not go there but of course
it's there's no war on blacks and puerto
rican kids that's what the world
is that's what's going to jail i i hate
i hate to agree with suge but
there it really there is there is
there is definitely a racial component
because if you look at the war on drugs
if you target street level dealers
you end up with a jail full of blacks
and puerto ricans absolutely and then
you know they need white guys to rape
and that's why you have dwi laws
i got it negative i do the thing about
the sniper the black sniper yes
and blah blah blah blah the punchline
was [ __ ] and a buick
and
[Laughter]
that's why it's funny though because the
reason it's funny
is because i don't understand why things
are funny hard consonants are funny
you know blah blah blah in a chevy or
blah blah blah in a in a
maximum it's not funny buick is funny
that's why and the fact that he wasn't
in a buick
is the reason i'm a comedy genius and
it's hard
it's hard to express okay but tunisia
he's from israel he's um his job is that
he's uh
he fiddles on roofs
and he survived 75
pogroms
and i left some things slide colin like
when you wear corduroys and your back
pockets touch i don't say nothing
when you got it i let it go
there's no gay black pirates in society
[Applause]
[Laughter]
these goofy white people and it must be
something very important going on
because they standing out here in the
sun and you know white people
don't agree do these things actually
make a difference yes it does
because we are hold on i'm sorry i'm
sorry white lady can you mind your
business
why black people are talking please
speaking of race what are the kobe
bryant thing that sounds like it's got a
little
your thing on it has a little racial
something the new word is physmograph
everybody should be horrified about it
yeah it's a machine if kobe gets
convicted it's a machine that they're
gonna put on his penis
to measure what makes him horny it's
true
it's true it's a real machine white
people it's a real machine
it's a real machine they're gonna decide
where to take his kids and i know i
look any old woman turned me on
yesterday how's that gonna be
whether i'm a rapist that turns me off
it turns me on it's so sick i
i can't imagine that and also if anyone
if anyone's wrapping a cuff on my penis
that's gonna get me going no matter what
exactly and no matter what they say if
it's dirty you're going to get up
or you're going to sit there like this
he has no there's no
wind loot it's a it's a new situation
because if he sits there and they're
showing him titties
and he's not reacting they're going to
go oh kobe's a monster he has no
feeling right so is he going to lose no
that is a dangerous thing it's like
clockwork orange
the movie nobody saw except because i'm
71 years old tonight
but that pleismograph this cup thing
it's only if you're it's if you're
convicted so a good way to avoid that
but the best way to avoid getting that
thing on is not right
that's a weird thing to decide
somebody's taste because if you're
sitting there like you said you got
somebody
putting a cop on your car sitting there
tell me all kinds of dirty stuff
anything can set you up we got a machine
to measure the horniness in ralphie's
titties
[Applause]
how about you kev ah you know what if i
wanted anyone to be president
i would want to be shaq cause shaq can
do whatever the hell he wants shaq can
call you in right now
and tell him that he wants to bomb
france they're gonna say but why shaq
they didn't do anything uh i don't know
i don't like the basketball team
i think the basketball team stinks i
want to drop a bomb on him i want to
dunk it
i want to do it that's what you want to
do
i want to do it that shaq
ate his balls he called me with that
shack and you think this shack is going
to be good yeah
[Applause]
it was the soccer moms this year now
it's the nascar dads
what's another demographic that
politicians should be courting and why
dom i think politicians should go after
the latinos
we are the largest minority in the u.s i
say we because although
i may be italian now i'm switching over
in order to be a more popular comedian
hey president bush have for your local
beaver supply your
mommy and mother
i think the politicians should be caught
in the irish in new york city
all they have to do is move the election
to the same day as the saint patrick's
day parade
and put free beer lucky charms and every
voting booth that's at least 2 million
voters who won't remember who they voted
for the next day
or the day after hi
patrice o'neill all right we should
court uh certified hookers
uh that would be a great demographic uh
most likely uh when she agrees to give a
little piece of her vote
the [ __ ] ain't gonna change her mind at
the polls the next day um
nothing hold up should we read that
again y'all that's what y'all gave that
shut up at the beginning that's if i
could see it from here
what happened if you'd flip that last
line at the beginning they wouldn't
be go down again flip that line at the
end
wait a minute most likely we keep going
most likely when she when she agrees to
give a little piece of her
vote the [ __ ] ain't going to change her
mind
at the polls all of a sudden y'all don't
even get that you know what kiss my ass
all right what drink so now hey
everybody how can i do a george bush
brother
hey everybody two jews walk into a bar
by it and then blow up a guy sitting in
a wheelchair
hey hey come on the woman soldier
thought that the naked tariffs was
carrying a stick of diamond
dynamite dynamite sorry but i guess
he was just glad to see him oh come on
folks
just joshing around
those [ __ ] those pictures and the
treatment of the prisoners were terrible
yeah but uh
would you rather have saddam or saudo me
did it did it come on folks
but seriously where are those weapons at
can you take it
you can have the n-word we get tommy
hilfiger back
no one wears it anymore
[Music]
[Music]
was he saying it to be mean or was he
trying to motivate these guys
well either way
it's true
[Music]
[Applause]
no it's like type a little faster [ __ ]
oh exactly i'll never forget the great
new rocky speech
all right let's move on okay what you
really want to say let's move on you two
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] are doing it again
i want to be a [ __ ]
keep your laws off my body
we will not be silenced and we
will go this whole government's got to
go and go now this is what life was like
before
choice oh such a nice day i think i'll
go have an abortion
oh i wonder what morgan freeman would
say about that
[Applause]
abortion abortion abortion aside oh
women
boring
look at this guy ready here's one rich
kid from one of those rich kid shows
and i'm up at boarding school and this
kid's from like some
town in connecticut you know i don't
know i can just say [ __ ] you i'm from
new york i can buy your family piss off
what you like i just thought i was great
i'd love to be able to say that to
somebody's family
no he said he could buy his family that
would be fantastic what are you saying
i think i can't believe you're wearing a
sweater with a hood
i wear this a lot i don't see what's
wrong with it's actually one of my
signature pieces
you should give them more credit for
that little brown riding hood that
sweater stinks
i don't know how the subject changed
from rich people to my lovely attire but
i'm just saying i wish i knew i wish i
had
was born to know what it was like to be
able to even think about saying that to
somebody
and be serious i'll buy your family
whatever right he says all he gonna do
he's saying that to other little rich
white people that probably got a little
less
money than he does he ain't saying that
to nobody black because we always can
fall back on
and i'll break your ass in half that's
that's black people
answer to everything what i'll kick out
break your ass in half
a new york times sunday new york times
which i know you guys can hear less
about because
it's not handed out by a five percent
muslim that just came out of jail
um but there's a new trend we're all
they say all these black dudes are on
the down low they say the deal where
they're going to gay bath houses but
they don't consider themselves gay
no what the hell is this do you guys
know about this wow yeah
you know what you know what why do you
think we're experts on this gay issue
why are you jim david on the show people
are coming at us with a bunch of
questions and i'm gonna question that
toupee on your head because i really
don't think that's your hair
color i really do i don't think that's
common there and i'm about to snatch
segment of society to keep it real even
sissies that's right
white people can go around being
flamboyant
and and we gotta still be like word is
born son pop me in the butt cheeks
germany france and canada are angered by
the pentagon's decision to cut them out
of that 18 billion dollars
worth of uh contracts so here's what
president bush had to say about this
ready
it's very simple our people risk their
lives friendly coalition folks risk
their lives and therefore the contract
is going to reflect that
that's what the u.s taxpayers expect
just as i stink as an impressionist who
cares
how do you think patrice should
rebuilding contracts be used to help
those who
help us look first of all can this goofy
country just
give us the truth i think we can handle
it just have him say
i'm giving all the jobs to my friends
why should we give up
why she's gonna be some kind of
explanation that was what he was looking
for no no no
no save that for boss at some point
he's just giving it to his friends why
don't you just say that he's just giving
it to his buddies
so what if he if we got control it's
it's i don't know if it's called
nepotism but it's called something
and and he's giving it to his voice you
get look the reason people hate this
show so much is because you got
your boys working and all the other
comics who think they're funny
but you got exactly stupid you know what
i'm saying well i'll tell you exactly
what it is you can't come out of the
bathroom for a ball fight and
ask your friend to buy you a drink i
know that's good old homespun
logic that was a good one you know how
to make everybody happy
buddies no here's how you make them all
happy i like the fact that this creep
had to like put this weird edge by going
the reason people my
people when i say shut up these other
goofy comics
first of all you didn't say that up
front so you want the audience to know
about the little
infighting the comedy scene second of
all do i even have to know
that there's a couple of bitter idiots
out there that want to be shut up colin
you do know
what is it here's the thing what here's
the thing
wait wait explain to us what sort of
that was we don't have a nice laugh
that was from the old uh marlborough
commercials oh it's like a mobile yeah
jesus if you've got an example exactly
you're 20 years old
[Applause]
germany and canada get to attack syria
and then let them rebuild syria there
you have it everybody's happy now
you see what i it's not funny it's just
uh first of all
where the hell where the hell is
shermany i said
[Laughter]
the gayest dude on it she's like 82
percent gay or something like that
it wasn't 82. liz pointed out a woman
pointed out he shaved his chest for the
show
you're a gay bird
okay we'll be right back we're two black
dudes a admitted serial killer and a
practicing homosexual i want to take
there's a
russians back in jail he has breast
implants been in for 25 years
he's got that you know he's in going to
illinois and he's got the big brothers
like yo and they're like
making them bloom and they got coke it's
like an exciting video
it sounds a little it sounds a little
harsh at first
in the middle with the red she has no
clue what any what's going on wait
all she wants to do is lift up her skirt
for the snoop dogg
and she doesn't know who richard speck
is you gotta explain to these people who
he is
or use an updated serial killer in your
jokes but he looks
more like with respect he looks just
like richard
but who is retrospect to a 19 year old
tenderloin like that she don't know
think of me as snoop dogg first of all
there's a there's a tv audience we're
trying to read
second of all all right we'll be right
back
[Applause]
i was wondering first can you do
something gay by mistake
that's the first question i've done a
few [ __ ] things that i didn't realize
until right after
i did it i i sat down and peed once
i uh i tucked uh i took my winter
sweaters into my pants one time
uh i did little [ __ ] low giggles like
i've uh i if i can't find stuff in the
cabinet too long if it takes too long
i'd get gayer as i can't find it i'm
like
where's the salt i know
but the gayest thing i ever did was uh i
was watching a male comic do a half hour
on comedy central dressed
in form-fitting jeans and a tight little
a tight little wife beater with a drum
set in the background
he's the gamer that's the game
yes guys lie and they cheat
do you yes it's bad or do you think it's
just genetic i don't think people should
be together for the whole world is it
genetic i don't think
no i think if a guy has a feeling he
wants to someone that's no
but don't you feel there's a certain
amount of genetic predisposition
that
you're insane just take it nobody that's
that that's the vagina
that's the vagina driving you and saying
listen one day you'll
learn how to not be take your vagina put
it over here
and take your take who you are that and
put it over there
wait instead of forcing us to like all
of you
when you could be a loser and i just
want to sleep with you but i don't want
the other part
that don't make no sense all right i'm
sorry you're right
he could be the next doctor phil with
that kind of compassion
but here's the point upstairs just now
with liz and amanda
and beth you know producers women so i'm
up there and we're about to bust bets
balls on something good we gotta do
something good
i start to slam liz and amanda were
there for the beginning of the slam i
lose them
because they're looking at a shoe and
talking about the shoe
now ladies that's not fun
we're too busy looking at our shoes
that's what happens what we're just
trying to say
is it really do you have to take it so
personally yeah
i have done nothing on the show
that's what i'm talking about keep doing
that high alert
you gotta ignore that once you learn to
ignore that
you'll be on your way to france that's
the whitest couple i've ever seen in my
life but why this couple did you say
like it's a criticism where you were
proud to be white that's right
you know everything you call and had a
baby it would explode from the light in
it
and that's good right don't say the n
word come on they're still friends
no go ahead get to that listen
shut up see women don't give us sex
to prove that we like you the longer we
wait that means oh he really likes me
men you we want sex from you because
that proves to us that you like us so if
you
if you go with me in the first date i'm
not gonna think you're a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
i'm gonna love you yeah i'm gonna take
you out i'm gonna treat you better
than you ever wanted but if you make me
wait the more you frustrate me
yes wait the bottom line is this
what happened was the sexual revolution
blew it for women before that
have sex you'd have to get married right
and what happened was somehow somebody
got them to think oh i'm sorry
feminist go right back to that
[Applause]